these are the latest pictures coming
from vietnam
and also from hong kong and germany and
it's very similar
images aren't there you might have got
the sense looking at these that there's
a uniform increase in covert 19 a second
wave across the world but actually
dig into the data and it's a slightly
more complex picture than that this
shows you
infection rates in those countries and
you can see just look at how low
vietnam is the higher this is the more
infections per 100 000 of the population
then you've got germany considerably
higher but it doesn't look like it's
starting to
spike up dramatically does it but now
have a look at hong kong an incredibly
steep rise in infections in hong kong at
the moment now
these countries three very different
stories and yet
all of them are under the same blanket
policy from the foreign office you don't
have to quarantine
if you're going coming back from any of
those countries and it raises some
questions doesn't it about that
policy we've taken some of those
countries which
uh are included within the exemption
list so you don't have to quarantine if
you're coming back from these countries
there are the white bars here and the
higher the bars are by the way
the higher infection rate so for
instance the uk they're 14 cases per
hundred thousand
most of these countries on the exempt
list are around that kind of level
but just look at a few others so you've
got portugal sweden and
spain now spain just added to that list
obviously uh in the last
week this half explains why but have a
look at these two countries say the
bahamas
85 cases per 100 000 much higher than
spain so is luxembourg again much much
higher about 210
cases per hundred thousand now why is it
by the way i've put the us just for
reference that why is it
that you don't necessarily uh have to
quarantine coming back from those
countries well
we don't know for sure the fca hasn't
been very clear about how it's coming up
with this policy
but one hint is it might have something
to do with the fact that there are more
people going to spain
to these other countries so this shows
you just basically tourism and travel
from the uk to these countries so spain
at the very top of the list there then
france then italy
and at the bottom you can probably just
about see luxembourg in the bahamas so
far fewer people
going there and if you combine those two
data series you get what um
i would call here a covid tourism risk
index
it's slightly unscientific but it gives
you a kind of sense of the impact that
you might well face
from those different countries and the
infection rates and the tourism and have
a look at this look sweden
is actually smack bang in the middle of
these supposedly safe countries
the bahamas down at the bottom
luxembourg in the middle rather than
being at the top so that's really
interesting
isn't it but have a look at a few of
these other countries as well portugal
up there actually below france when it
comes to
the impact france although it's got low
infection rates it has high
tourism and there you can see spain
really high well above the others that
half explains
why spain has suddenly gone on to that
list but some people might look at
france and wonder whether
it may soon be next